so first of all welcome to the uh first
session of tuesday is the second day of
ndc certainly very happy to be back here
i am uh claire novotny i'm a program
manager now they're calling us product
managers at microsoft on the new get
team so how many of you are familiar
with nuget
most of you fantastic
um you're all i assume mostly.net
developers since you're here that's
great thank you for using.net certainly
like that and it's my favorite framework
in this talk we're going to start with a
basic library we're going to
validate that we don't have any breaking
changes across versions we're going to
turn it into a package following some of
our best practices that we recommend
add some automatic versioning add some
multi-targeting
and you know then we'll move on to talk
about supply chain security and how
nuget helps you improve that and make
things more secure and better so
at the end we'll have plenty of time for
some q a so if you have some burning
questions
please
ask them and i'll be here
both you know after and later today as
well and at the party this evening so if
you have questions about nuget or other
things around.net please send them my
way and if i don't know the answer i
will certainly be happy to connect you
with my colleagues that do know the
answer
so with that
let's uh get started
so how many of you
um
create or maintain a new get package
and is this for
internal use
open source
okay good mix
how about consuming packages
okay that's okay most of you here
and
do you
do you share code with other teams in
your company or clients using nuget so
stuff that's not going to the public but
you know we want to do some reuse
good good all right this is a very
different answer than it would have been
you know five years ago and four years
ago when people were doing all kinds of
other weird forms of sharing like you
know copying files around that then
would have to be updated
how many of you familiar with
multi-targeting
okay so good we'll come back to that one
and
for those of you that are using
multitargeting
why are some of the reasons you're using
it
just shout out
okay yeah
all right very good
so
we have a number of best practices on at
nougat that we've been recommending for
a while although you know we certainly
get questions about this all the time
and we've been introducing new features
over the years as well to help improve
privacy and security and safety
as well so package icon is a relatively
new thing that's been about a year year
and a half old which allows you to embed
a package icon in your package rather
than referencing it from a file and that
sounds trivial but the reason you care
especially as a consumer is that every
time you reference a file on the
internet you have to retrieve it which
then yields your ip address and
potentially information to third parties
that's a privacy leak so nuget we are
encouraging folks to use icons in the
package and for those that are coming
from newget.org we will proxy those
icons from third parties if they are
there so we're trying to protect your
privacy there uh
read me how many folks have a readme in
their package
a few
okay how many of you would like to have
a readme in the packages you use
okay yeah yeah
well so this is a feature where you can
authors can put a readme in the package
which will then be available anywhere
the package is offline and such and that
so you can get make it easier to get
started
license information certainly a crucial
bit um if it doesn't have a license
can't really use it it doesn't it's
ambiguous right
so you have to know what the license is
and nuget allows you to do that so we're
going to make sure we do that correctly
symbols and source link are again
somewhat more recent but how many folks
are trying to debug something in
production and saying hey look um i
don't know where that came from or i'm
trying to step into some code
all right and did you have symbols for
it in some in all cases sometimes
would you wish you did especially if
it's an open source library and you're
like i know the code is there on github
why can't i step into it
so having the symbols along with source
link allows you on the debugger to
automatically locate that source code
download it and step into it at debug
time
and more recently as of visual studio
17.1 i want to say the latest one allows
you to navigate there in the editor as
well so if you control click a file or
you know shift f5
anyway you go to the definition it will
download those symbols locate the source
and step into the code directly to make
it easier to just
navigate those third-party code
and we'll show you how to do that here
and
momentarily
so let's um switch over to visual studio
and create a package
i'm using visual studio 2022 17.2
preview i don't know 6 the latest one
and
we're just going to come here and create
a new
package open new project
here we go
and i'm just going to create a
basic class library cool
and let's just call it ndc london
because you know that's where we are
i'm going to pick.net 6. it's the latest
long term support which means it's
supported for three years
dot net 7 is coming out later this year
it is a
short-term support but the quality is
the same there's no difference in
quality it's just supported until the
next major long-term support comes out
so definitely encourage you to use
the latest version if you can
so i'm going to come in here and
let's go and create this package i'm
going to add an icon to it and the first
thing i'm going to do is just drag
this lovely tulip
because i like tulips i was just in
amsterdam
earlier in april and saw the amazing
tulip fields so i like tulips as icons
but
putting it into visual studio here is
not enough to get it into the package
so instead
i'm going to come in
here hit properties
and here we go
any of you seen the new properties page
yet in visual studio
you know you can search
so i can come in here and say i don't
really know where this icon is
i'm going to come in here and find it
and
here we go
oops
there we go
browse and i'm going to go find this
thing on the disk
big icon big dialogues make it harder to
navigate here we go
deaf ndc london
and we're going to select the tulip
with that
we should be
good once it decides to put it there
there's also all kinds of other items
here so you can certainly search for the
rest of your properties
and edit this a lot more easily than you
could before and it shows you a lot of
the defaults that you may have not
realized you could change so i'm not
going to go into all of that here but
you can certainly poke around and see
all the package related items here
the one thing i will add
is we'll go to the license let's set
that to say
spdx
and
uh spd how many folks are familiar with
spdx
so it's just four
weird letters
um spdx is a industry-wide
set of abbreviations for the most common
license types so instead of having to
embed a text file of mit or apache or
whatever it's saying hey look we know
these are the most common things let's
just put the word mit in there and we'll
recognize the expression
um it can get much more complicated in
terms of
you know booleans and whatnot but this
allows machines to read this thing and
make decisions on what your package has
for compliance reasons
so we're going to set that here hit save
and we can look here at the properties
page and see exactly what it did because
i don't know about you but i like the ui
sometimes if i'm learning but when i
want to know how something works i'm
going to go straight to the project file
and
come in here
hit edit project file
and we can see here that it added this
item which really just tells it hey look
we're going to include this file in the
package at this location
and it's at the package icon property to
you know the name of the file so this
will be there and if we build this
package
and hit pack
it will build this here
and in a moment we can pull this up in
nuget package explorer and take a look
at this lovely package we have so far
copy this here
how many folks have are familiar with
nuget package explorer
few
so for those that are less familiar
nuget package explorer
is
a program that allows you to inspect new
get packages
as the name implies and it also will
tell you whether you're following the
best practices there as well so
i pull this up double click come on open
it's thinking
all right
there we go
nuka package explorer is both a windows
desktop application and a website more
recently as of last summer so if you go
to nuget.info
you can get this in webassembly and it
will work everywhere so if you're using
a mac or
your phone
it will work there now it will it's not
optimized for mobile screen sizes
currently but it still loads and you can
run it
there
so if you see this package we see here
that it has the tulip icon but we're
missing symbols and it says we're
getting a whole bunch of red and what
that's telling us here is that there are
missing steps in order to make this
package
be able to be debuggable and
reproducible and validatable by other
systems
now instead of having to go fiddle with
a whole bunch of different properties
which you certainly can do
we've made it easier the net foundation
has made it easier to
just add a package reference to
reproducible builds
and it will do all of the stuff for you
instead of having to
you know set this stuff manually so if
i'm going to come in here
and i'm going to go to the package
manager ui
and we're going to go search for
builds
and don't worry about the names this
slide deck is available the qr code is
at the front and it will be on screen
later so
you don't have to worry about memorizing
any of this stuff
but we had install and it adds a
reference to
this package which is a build time
reference
it doesn't need any doesn't take any
dependencies on your application at
runtime at all
and now
if we rebuild this
and we look at the result again
as soon as it finishes
here we go
we will get some green check boxes
instead of red ones
here we go
oh why did it not like that
let's try this one more time clean
rebuild
let's do this one more time oh i didn't
build instead of pack that's why it
doesn't help if i build it and don't
actually tell it to create the package
it won't get very far
here we go
and it is telling me here that we have
compiler flags and has symbols in no
source link
the reason for that is it's hard to add
source information if we are not in a
repository so let's go do that
so i'm going to come in here and i don't
know how many folks have seen this and
get in visual studio
i mean it's a big product we've been
adding a lot of features
i can just turn this into a git
repository right here i don't have to go
into a command line or anything else
let's come in i'm going to add a get
just use the existing template
i'm going to have it
use the mit license
let me check the box let me give it a
readme file because i want one of those
too
and i'm going to call this thing ndc
london because
that's what it is
so now we have a git repository
and
one more time
we're going to just rebuild this and
pack it
there we go
it comes back
come on
pack
i really wish it was a keyboard shortcut
for pack instead of having to get it on
the other hand most of the time you're
doing this in ci i hope right
anyone still building and right click
publish from visual studio
good answer
that being no one
that's my kind of crowd either hopefully
it's either you know github actions or
azure devops or something like that
so here we go
and we have a different option and it's
just saying hey there are some files in
here we don't know about and that's okay
it's getting better and if it's on your
ci server this will all be green there
are certain kinds of things that work
on ci that do not work in the local
environment and this is one of them so
take my word for it
add this package run it and see i this
will all be green
so
that um how many folks here
have um familiar with package validation
nobody all right so you came to the
right talk because that is one of my
most favorite features that we added in
net six that nobody seems to know about
yet
and it was blogged about
so i'm gonna come in here and
uh turn on package validation because
we're gonna want that later
so let me set this property here to true
neighborhood package out
and
we'll come back to that
there we go
click
all right
so
cross
compatibility has become a mainstream
requirement for net library authors
however we haven't had tooling to help
you make this you know easier in your
project so you know it's easy to miss
emerging platforms especially if it's
not one you regularly use i mean how
many folks are testing things for say
alpine linux even if you're building a
linux container
maybe not everyone maybe you are maybe
are you testing your thing on the latest
iot device maybe there's another runtime
somewhere that there's a
native interop that you might need
there's a lot of scenarios that you may
not be testing because testing is
expensive and while we're all trying to
test the most common cases it's easy to
miss the edge cases
so there's a number of issues that can
come up across
package versions
there could be breaking changes
that could be accidental you didn't mean
to break it
but there's a difference between source
compatibility and binary compatibility
and
it's easy to miss in a just local dev
environment because you hit compile it
works i mean we expect it to run i mean
after all you know we're not using
javascript when c-sharp says it compiles
we tend to believe it right
so other options or other issues might
be mismatches between the public api
and an implementation api
so if you're doing any form of native
interop you might have seen some
packages have this you know
libs and runtimes directories in them
that's because they might need slightly
different internal implementations if
they're accessing
libraries that are specific and native
to the device
geolocation is a great example on phones
each operating system has a different
way to do it
there's other similar things with
cryptography and other
many scenarios which have different
implementations inside but we need to
make sure that the public surface area
is the same or we might get a runtime
exception when the it doesn't match up
incompatibilities across tfms is another
one that is easy to sometimes overlook
so suppose we need to target net
standard 2.0 which is the
common least common denominator right
now across all supported net platforms
and
we want to add additional capabilities
that light up with say net 6 such as
support for
string optimize
overloads to minimize allocations you
might do this for performance reasons
there are many ways to do this and if
you use an if-def
for example you might
have an issue in some cases and we'll
come back to that because that
read-only char
read-only span of char method that's the
super cool fast one
might be therefore.net six
and it might say do something with a
string for net standard
if they're not both there you might have
something that is built against the net
standard version expecting a string
and now at runtime it gets the net 6
version
and oops
not there
so what can we do here
so package validation as the name
implies helps make sure your package is
correct
and we'll flag you of things that like
these that it will find
see
one of them is a baseline version
you can specify a baseline version of a
package and say hey look
if here's the thing to compare against
make sure that what i'm working on now
has you know is compatible with it and
let me know if it doesn't
compatible runtime
again as the name implies helps make
sure all of the runtime implementations
the public surface area matches across
versions
and compatible framework does a similar
thing across compatible tfms
so it's aware of the tfm rules the
target frameworks
and it makes sure that for example that
dot net standard
exist in a net six one
but if you have something other like a
xamarin one it won't try and do the
wrong kind of comparison it's aware of
what should run
everywhere
so let's take a look at how this works
with
um a baseline version to see how this
can help us
avoid some
problematic changes
so let's come back
and
go
alrighty so
what you're doing package validation
so in this case suppose we wanted to add
that overload that we talked about right
so we're saying hey look i have do
something with a string and on.net 6 or
later i want to use this new fancy
overload method here
um
is this going to work well you know
we build it it's going to run we can
build
you know cool it builds and you know we
could say
let's move on
but we're smarter than that we're going
to turn on the baseline version checking
and let's say that you know we've
already built we've published the 1.0
version somewhere it could be our
private github repository or private new
get feed it could be nuget.org
now i'm going to say you know now we're
working on version two it doesn't matter
a different version
i'm gonna say hey we're comparing
against version one
and now
if i hit pack
we're going to see some differences
um
let's try rebuilding that
there we go
pack
okay
that
was just working
uh
all right um
it would also help if i use the right
demo
so all right we're going to come in here
and
say that this is the
connect method with a string overload
another common case
so i'm going to come in here and we're
going to add here a
that was my next demo by the way
we'll come back to that one
we're going to come here and add a
parameter and
visual studio is being slow today
all right conference wi-fi let's just
blame it on that um
let's add a overload in here this will
be something that is source compatible
um
and not necessarily uh binary compatible
so let's come in here let's add a time
span
or there we go time span
you know timeout
default
like that if i can type
all right
now
this time we'll see a difference i
promise
and it's making me a liar
that is correct
for the win
thank you all right
adding the old one was the correct
solution to this problem it would help
if
we reproduce the issue as you might do
accidentally so in this case
we see here that
and i will zoom in here on this message
that
the
there's a method here the connect string
that exists on the baseline that does
not exist here on
the net 6 version in this current one
and that's because we added something
that is source compatible but a binary
breaking change and as we've
demonstrated
previously
reverting that and adding the correct
overload will solve the problem and you
will not have an error how is the
question here
so the question here is how does the
validator know where it locates the
prior version from and
the answer is it's going to follow the
same nuget config versions that
are already there for your solution so
just like you would add or change a
package version in your solution it's
just pulling that down from
wherever the search paths are leading it
the question is will it prioritize the
local cache uh yes it will so if it's
already on your disk it will locate it
there and in this case for example i
have a local package folder this isn't a
package that's actually on nuget.org and
it still works because it's locating it
there
okay so
multi-targeting
wow the computer is extra slow today
so how many folks have seen
the frameworks tab on nuget.org
anyone
a few people
okay
so this was a top ask saying look i'm
adding a package i want to know if it
makes sure it works on my machine
and how do i know what's in there and
we've added a feature to nuget.org that
helps you display the all the frameworks
that it supports to save you some
trouble
and we'll take a look at that in a
moment
but for multi-targeting itself
we've already talked about some of the
reasons you might want to do it
and
some of them might be programs that need
to run on multiple platforms and need to
take advantage of native underlying
cryptography primitives
net standard 2.0
it is the most common lowest common
denominator
that said
it stuck at a level from several years
ago and is not going to have all of the
latest apis
so netstandard 2o is great if you have
the functionality you want and need in
it please use it
but don't be constrained by it if it's
if you want to go beyond it
it also allows you to have different
dependencies on different target
platforms so there might be some cases
where you might need one set of
dependent packages for
you know net framework but others for
net six and if you're using only.net
standard 2o
you won't be able to separate the two
out
so there are different reasons to do
different ways to do that and as we've
discussed it's critical that the public
surface area is compatible here because
otherwise we're going to get mismatches
at runtime
and we can kind of show that here in the
other demo that i was
showing
there we go
and we're going to come back here
and
all right
spinning
i have four instances of visual studio
open and
i don't think it likes my machine very
much
all right
so i'm going to come in here let is
enable package validation
it is thinking i don't it doesn't like
tuesday morning does it
all right so we've already looked at
some of the code that was the one here
that
you know we might simply say look we're
going to do this we're going to target
net standard 2o and we're going to add
some fancy-schmancy new wayforward.net
6.
we're going to ship this and a customer
is going to come in and say
why isn't this working i'm getting all
these weird runtime exceptions
and we can prevent that simply by
turning this package validation on
and now this time when i build and pack
this project
we will again see that it is going to
catch this for us and
okay here as promised we have
here
it's thinking come on an error and it's
telling us that hey again this method
here is on the net standard version but
not on the net 6 version so it's similar
to the baseline comparison except it's
across compatible target frameworks
here we go
and the solution here to this
is
add a method overload so instead of
doing an if def let's just have both on
the net 6 version so i'm going to come
in here and say hey look um let's just
get rid of this
else turn this into
an end if
and now
if i pack
it will be successful because on the net
standard version it only has the string
version and on the net 6 version it has
both so something that is
built and linked essentially against the
net standard version
will continue to use the less optimized
implementation however it will still run
and you won't have runtime exceptions
all right powerpoint thank you
that's um
it really doesn't like me today how does
it
alright
come on
um
all right
moving on
click
all right versioning
this is an area where we've gotten a lot
of questions in the past i've certainly
heard this on the internet on twitter
it's people asking you know hey look
we're doing continuous integration
continuous delivery
that's cool
but you know how do i make sure that all
the versions are unique because if i
have them in the project file like that
that means every time someone commits i
have to increment it and that's kind of
silly that's a lot of noise
or you know you might have
different ways of doing that with say
scripts that run in different branches
or different
ways of using
variables on your build server
some of you the tags are a common
popular way of saying let's do a major
minor that way
so there's a lot of opinions uh on the
internet surprise surprise
at nougat we have a view that
we want and value immutability and
reproducibility
most of all
above everything else
that's to say that in the future say
three years from now on a different
build server in a different environment
i want to be able to check out a
particular commit
build it and have a byte for byte com
equal version of that file including all
the file versions including all the
hashes and checksums
that makes it easier to validate that it
doesn't contain malicious code and it
makes sure that you know it's not doing
funny things along the way
so
in order to do that um
we can't use tags because
tags can be changed
you might say i
made a mistake let me say update it to a
different commit and three years from
now there's no guarantee that that tag
is going to be the same and if your
version is based on that
it won't be a reproducible build
same thing with environment variables or
build i mean that's just a given right a
different build server different process
no all bets are off
so the one we recommend
is something called nerdbank.git
versioning
it is a project that's a member of
the.net foundation
and the project shares a similar mindset
where it is aiming for complete
immutability and reproducibility
and it does that by maintaining a
version file in the repository
so you don't have to increment it on
every commit
but you do have to touch it on a major
minor and that's okay at least you know
that's a reasonable compromise that we
see where if i'm working on 1.1
that's cool i'll get 1.1 point
whatever
and then later i can change hey i want
to ship 2.0
at some point i just have a step that
says let's release 2.0 set the version
and move on
and it supports pre-release tags as well
so let's take a look at how this can
work so we're going to come back here to
our
library and i can close
this one maybe it will
free up some resources
go away
come on
all right come back to the command line
dc london
so their bank get versioning is
available as a nuget package it also
works as a global command which saves
you some steps to install it in your
project so if i come in here
and i can do
the install step
so come back
here
all right
we do
it's really it's
thinking about switching to a directory
i don't know what's going on today all
right
so
let's commit the previous changes
that's from when we added the repository
let's just move on
and let's go ahead here and add nbgv
instead of nbgv
install
and this will come in here and add the
files and reference that you need in
your project
so we come in here
and it's thinking as is seems to be the
mode of the day and we're going to come
back here to our project and see what it
did
so
we're going to come here and
rebuild this
and we should see here momentarily
that
it
added a version so we come in here let's
come in let's open the package
and it should be version 1.0 point i
don't know something because you don't
really know and i've stopped caring
and a lot of people have strong
preferences they want to release a 1.0.0
or
i think that a lot of people
put too much emphasis on that last point
nobody really pays attention to it and
if you look at other ecosystems like
node and npm there are all kinds of
crazy versions anyway so don't worry
about it um
so let's come in here
and
let's take a look at what it added so we
come in here and look at the version
json
it added here
um
here we go
open it up in this other window
grab it
all right so saying 1.0 i'm going to
come in here we're using main as a
branch spec
and
let's commit this because it's not going
to do much until it's committed so
it has to have a starting version to go
on
okay hit a
get come in
m
version
cool
now
we should have here a version
and it does this by adding a file to all
of the projects in the solution so if we
come back in here we'll see that it has
a directory.build.props
so if i open this up
there we go
it adds a file to the root of the
directory that allows you to say add
stuff and properties to all projects
underneath it
how many folks have seen
directory.build.props or targets
some of you okay so that's a neat trick
there's a lot more online about that but
certainly if there's common things
especially if you have packages or you
know icons and other such things
don't repeat yourself
that's a way of refactoring common ms
build settings whether it's references
or anything else into a common location
so um that's been supported there for
many years but most a lot of people just
don't know about it so there's a tip
it adds this in here so let's go ahead
and
build this now
we should get a version and
[Music]
here we go
this time
six
wait that's the wrong
i did build didn't i
let's pack this
go
all right
i'm going to move on
it does increment automatically but we
can see that by looking at different
commands so if i come in here i can do
the
uh
view commands if i want to say like what
information is in here
i can come in and say
like nbgv.getversion
thanks
yes paste
and it's going to tell me that the
version of calculated here is 1.0.1
and that has different versions like
here's the
versionin.net here's the assembly
version because we want to make sure
that we're not you know incrementing
things too much for net framework where
assembly binding is more strict
and because it is a pre-release tag it
calculates a bunch of other stuff here
now that's neat but suppose i want to do
something more with it like in a build
script
i want something that's machine parsable
i can say here format
json and we'll get a lot more
information and this is really cool if
you pipe this into powershell which can
support pulling in json objects natively
and use a dot notation to
directly access any of this data
when run on a build server it can set
environment variables so there's lots of
different ways of getting to this
in your various build environment so
there's lots of stuff calculated
and there's configurable more
documentation as online get hashes
timestamps height
branches
all of this is available so if you want
to stamp in the branch name into your
binary you can do that with this so
very powerful tool and is recommended
all right
supply chain so supply chain security is
a huge topic
it's a whole other talk really it's many
other talks over many hours and i highly
recommend that you spend some time
examining that
what we're going to do here is a bit of
a crash course
the key points are that
attackers are becoming increasingly
sophisticated
they are targeting dependencies open
source projects small companies there's
nothing too small for attackers to
target because they are looking for any
way into other organizations
so you know don't think that hey look
we're a two-person shop
nobody's going to care about us
that's not true anymore maybe it was a
few years ago but
right now these days everyone needs to
think about where their dependencies are
coming from how are they getting built
and make sure that they are not the next
entry point i don't think anyone wants
to see their name on this list
these are some more common of the
infamous attacks including one from 2021
on dependency confusion in which
the same package might exist in multiple
feed sources
and if you have conflicting names it may
not be clear
which
location it's being pulled from so you
might get like an interception there
so another way to look at it is that you
know
we're getting code you know off the
internet
we don't really know who wrote it i mean
some person in github with some handle
that you know people like
you know are we really reading all that
code
i mean
open ssl kind of proves otherwise with
heartbleed right i mean it was open
source why didn't anybody see it it's a
very popular cryptography library but
years and years and had massive flaws
it runs as you on your machine
and that's not just powershell scripts
any dll.net dll has a module initializer
that runs automatically on load
it doesn't have to even you don't even
know it's there necessarily unless you
are looking for it
so
there are ways that you can run stuff
and you have to make sure you trust the
sources
i mean it's kind of surprising that it's
still working quite honestly
so what is nuget doing to help improve
the story here
package source mapping is a feature we
released last fall and that's a way to
mitigate that dependency confusion
attack known as samsa
it lets you specify
a config file which you know in your new
get config wet packages are coming from
what source
so suppose you have you know contoso dot
something and you have internal packages
in particular that are coming from you
know your corporate feed
well
before this
if you someone else was to say upload
contoso.somethingtoynundgut.org
it might be
a
50 50 chance which one's going to come
you're going to get the one from the
internal feed or this one from an
attacker on nuget.org
well i don't like those odds so we did
something about that so
we released a
feature called source mapping and more
recently we have a preview of a tool
that allows you to
generate those config files for you
because it can be a pain to get started
so this is on our blog on the nuget blog
but if i come back here to
the terminal
and it decides to load i'm going to
come back
all right
go here to an example here
to nuget package explorer
um
source code it's open source you like it
please submit contributions um
i'm going to run here the command that
will generate this initial file for you
and that is just package source mapper
i've already installed the tool
there we go
and it's going to generate a config file
looking at where things are coming from
today and saying all right assume this
is correct let's stop it going forward
and you can review this of course and
edit it so it's looking at the current
config
and we'll generate this file here in a
moment
as soon as it does there we go
so if i come in here i can we can take a
look
uh there we go
there we go wait
you can see what it generated you get
package source mapping the
yep
too many things to start with you get in
this project
most of you probably don't have too many
files to start with you get
in any event
this is a list this is you can paste
this into your nuget config
instead of the existing package sources
and
it will
tell you where all these things are
coming from this project has a lot of
dependencies but it also has several
different sources
some stuff is coming from that private
feed some stuff is coming from another
private feed and the rest are coming
from nuget.org this is a this is a
mapping
the existing this is a preview tool it
can be made better there could be some
wild cards here but it's a starting and
some a starting point that you don't
have to do by hand
yes there's a question
so that question is what version of
nuget supports this i believe that is in
version six and higher so there's the
one there
nuget you can always use the latest
tools against older projects so i highly
recommend always using the latest tool
chain for security and feature reasons
package signing is a technique where you
can prevent packages from being tampered
with in transit
nuget signs all packages coming from it
that live in its repository and there
are ways where authors can individually
sign their packages so that you know it
came from them
and was hosted on our feed there's not
much you need to do there except there
are advanced policies where your
organization can say hey i only want
packages that come from say microsoft or
from publisher
whomever and you can lock that down if
you want
how many folks are familiar with
cves and alerts vulnerabilities
a few
i think this is something that we as
developers all need to take a
responsibility for cves are the database
and listing of vulnerabilities
um we're doing a
better we're adding more exposure to
this in
uh visual studio and the cli and making
it possible to
see these kinds of issues
so let's take a look here at
the
a common library suppose we want to add
a
zip compression to something and
we're going to add sharp ziplib which is
the very popular library to do
um
wow okay which is a very popular library
to do
compression on.net
it recently had a vulnerability on
version
1.32 i believe and it would be very easy
to miss that if we weren't paying
attention to it so let's take a look at
what this might look like
you know
project we have this
package no big deal
we build it
and you know
there's no errors
no big deal right but unbeknownst to us
there might be a pretty high
vulnerability here
so
there is a command
that you can run on the cli and then
also via visual studio that we can say
um
the um
that will show us the vulnerabilities so
let's see package
reality demo
where'd it go
that's what i wanted
so if i run here netlist packages it
will show me here that
you know here i'm running it with
vulnerable command and it's going to
tell me what the vulnerabilities are on
this package and say hey i might want to
look at this
and see the details about it
now
we're making additional work we're
taking on additional work to make this
run automatically on restore so you
don't have to see this on a special
command if you're running this just on
your ci it should show up there too
but it also does show up in visual
studio so if i'm coming here and
browsing my packages and i'm seeing this
i might see this little yellow box
and i see a yellow triangle at the top
and if i click on it it will tell me
that same information
so if i update that to the latest
version
it will go away and you know we fix the
problem
this information is also on nuget.org so
we're trying to make this available to
you
every which way to try and make you more
aware of these issues
we're also exposing a transitive
vulnerability mechanism coming soon as
well where it's not just where your
first level dependencies but the entire
graph underneath that if you have
something vulnerable let me know as well
so moving on
when it decides to draw the screen
we're also taking steps to add support
for
uh there we go
we're adding support for prefix
reservations so there is a feature on
nuget.org that we added sometime last
summer which allows you to request
certain
the contoso.something
not be available to say the general
public say hey look we are a company
we're making stuff we have packages with
this name
let's
block that and you can email us and we
will grant that request the
documentation is on our website for that
and we have since enabled mandatory
two-factor authentication for all
accounts on nuget.org so this is
something that was completed recently
without much fanfare but shouldn't be
because you're all using two-factor
authentication today right so you
already have it
another feature that we have that is
shipping right now in 17.2
is central package management
so this is a way where you can have the
same
dependency versions across your entire
set of projects and specify them in one
place
prior to this you might you know be
familiar you add a project and the
version was in each project file so now
if you wanted to update those versions
you had to update them in each project
file
or
some of you might have manually gone in
to do fancy things with directory.build
files and such
so we've gone ahead and productized a
feature that many teams have been using
internally for years
and so this is not new in any way
from a technology standpoint it's just
one where we've taken it and refined it
and saying we're going to ship this out
to everybody else because this is
something that everybody needs
so there's a new file here called
directory.packages.props
that contains packages and versions and
then later on if you want to
override them say look
i want to say you know in a particular
project maybe it's a test project i want
to use a different one
you can override and opt out and get
something different so you have
flexibility there
also enable you to turn on transitive
pinning and that will help lift
the transitive versions higher so that
you can get rid of the version downgrade
prompts
how many folks here have seen that you
know you've added a package you get
these weird warnings with like hey this
yeah you know i don't think any of us
have ever figured out how to really
solve that you know so add this as a top
level reference right you're like well
what
turn on central package transit of
pinning and all that goes away
the other thing too is that this works
with all projects including all your old
legacy projects
it does need the latest ms build and
tooling but that can build the old stuff
as well so
let's just take a very quick look here
and i think i have just one more road
map slide at the end here because we are
coming
up towards the top of the hour
we're going to come here and take a look
at central package management
and here we're going to take a look at
this
class library one we can see here
it's adding a reference to
newtonsoft.json
but there's no version in here because
it doesn't need one
and the reason for that
is that we've specified it here
in
this central location
so this project has
ascentdirectorypackages.props
and that will have the master list of
all of your packages and versions it's
not saying that every project gets a
reference to it
it's just saying hey if you do reference
it use this version
now
if i want to change that and say hey
look
i don't want to use version 13 somewhere
i want to use say version 9
maybe it's a test project and you need
an explicit version we can do that here
and
if we come in
look at transit of pinning
we can turn this on or off and it's
defaults to off
there was a 50 50 set of circumstances
whether some you know half the people
liked it better defaulted with off half
the people liked it on could not win
this one so
i think it's best practice to turn it on
but
you need to see what works for your
project
what happens here is that if we were to
add a reference just to version this
project and have it bring in
newtonsoft.json it would have been
version 12
but we want version 13
so we turn this feature on and we get
that
and if these version numbers are all
saying hey this is really confusing
we show this to you too so if i come in
here
i can come in and look at the packages
look at the version
and here in the
ux
i see here it says version 13.
and if i look here at the one with
transit of pinning
it shows that here as well here's the
first top level package
it's version
you know one whatever that brings in
newtonsoft.json13 because we've turned
this on
and now
if i turn this off
you'll see here let me just turn this
off
which is the default behavior if you
don't enable it
it'll do run restore and you can see
here and if you just saw that here it
popped up to version 12
or pop down because that's the default
when
the bson library will pull that in so it
helps unify this
in a more central way
and here we have the version override
if you look at the packages i know it's
small but here it says version nine so
again it all works it shows it to you in
the
solution explorer so you're not guessing
about what you're actually getting here
and that is you do need the latest
visual studio tools for that 7.2 isn't
currently in preview it will be released
soon um
so we have that
other things we have coming up package
scoring is one a lot of people have
asked hey a lot of packages out there
how do i know which one i should use
give me a clue help me figure this out
so we're we have a proposal out there on
our
github repo we're working on
implementing this over the summer and
fall to
give you some indicators about package
quality security velocity and best
practices
we will have a v1
you know later this year hopefully
we're also turning that package list
into a machine readable format so
instead of having to
grep and grok and parse all these
screens we'll just let you skip that
step and give you that output
the package source mapping tool that was
in preview we'll ship later hopefully
you know more intelligence to it so
groups
more things
uh
transit of dependencies are coming in
the package manager ui in visual studio
so right now we've only seen you know
that in the solution explorer where i
can drill down
but
how do i know what packages are way down
there even if i'm browsing
in visual studio i want to see all this
stuff so we're going to put that in
there
search by tfm
very popular ask saying hey look
i want to look for a package but i want
to only only show me results that are
like compatible with this that i can
actually use here
so don't just return the world
so we're working on adding that um as
well so that's coming
all of this is on github our roadmap is
there please you know
chime in upvote things we do very much
look at upvotes on issues to help drive
engagement interest
and with that i think we have just a few
minutes for
some additional questions but i'll be
around
later after this and you know this
afternoon and definitely at the party
this evening
please tweet at the team at me we'll try
and route your questions
um
but yeah so i don't know if there's any
questions from the last few minutes
we'll certainly take that
the suggested yesterday
version to select is it
previously 0.000
so the question is what is the suggested
baseline version to use is it 0 1.0 or
the previous release
it really all depends on your scenario
what are you trying to compare against
are you looking at the next major
version or you know what's the latest
one you've shipped
so
in you know for me for example i would
probably look at i've shipped 1.1.
you know 47 because i'm using get
nerdbank.com versioning and i never have
a zero shipping release that just
doesn't exist
so i'll put 1.1.47 is the baseline and
say look i'm working on 1.2 point
whatever show me those differences
there is a way in the tool to say look
suppose it is a known breaking change
you there's an xml file there's
configuration it's documented you can
acknowledge these changes and say look
thank you for pointing that out i'm good
with that let's move on so you can
absolutely uh say you know suppress
certain warnings and errors that you
know about
and does package validation
basically replace the
public api
the question is the
package validation replaced the public
api analyzer so
i'm not 100 sure
what the public api analyzer checks i
believe that was one for program
compatibility against.net framework
okay the question is it might generate a
text file for comparison maybe possibly
in this case this is more programmatic
and this is built into the sdk itself so
there's no additional tooling to install
either so in the past i mean there have
been other versions there's a community
project out there that there's several
that can do these kinds of checks you
can compare them and do diffs
that's fine it might work for your
scenario
we wanted to ship one in the box so that
is there by default for everybody um so
that's what's there we have this
question there
the link's not working um i will fix
that um later so i will we'll see why
that's not working
it's the same deck from porto is there
um i will check and see why that's not
working thank you
so the question is um is nerve bank get
versioning of best practice normally the
ci build server does the versioning for
me uh the answer is a hundred percent
yes
um as mentioned one of the concerns
about using versioning that comes from a
build server
is reproducibility something happens to
a build server it moves to a different
build script
i can't you know you give it to somebody
else that doesn't have your build server
they're not going to be able to just get
that same exact binary without lots of
additional work and guarantee that
so when looking to make sure that we can
get the same binary every time just by
running the build script
we're aiming for something that can be
you know can work that way
so the question is is that the produce
symbol builds package the versioning
package uh yes
um so the answer is we want reproducible
builds across reproducible builds helps
ensure certain build settings are there
and compiler flags are automatically set
for you that symbols are generated and
stored in the package it's that's
documented on its page
uh it doesn't do anything for you about
versioning so versioning is you know
opinionated the two different things so
you would need both in this case
and with that um i'll take one final
question and i think then we're at
dependency time the system.txt
expressions vulnerability in it
i never showed up on visual studio or
anything like that the only way i found
about it was using a
website
the question is is there a there's some
package and substitute that contained a
dependency that had a vulnerability
i believe that and it didn't show up uh
that believe that's coming as part of
the transitive vulnerabilities work
that's going to be surfaced so right now
we would have shown you if and
substitute is vulnerable
not any of its dependencies
so as transitive ones get surfaced that
should show up
but please you know let me know and i
believe there's an issue to surface that
and we can i can point you to that
that's coming very soon
so thank you very much enjoy the rest of
your conference and i'll see you all
tonight at the party